-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Yesterday was Election Day
and "Late Night"
is now projecting
the Democrats will pick up
at least one seat
at Thanksgiving dinner.
[ Laughter ]
In an interview last night
with NBC News,
South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham said,
"Hats off to the Democrats
for performing well
in swing districts."
Oh, yeah, hats way off!
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Senator
Raphael Warnock
and Republican challenger
Herschel Walker
are set to head to a runoff
on December 6th
to decide Georgia's Senate race.
And, if you think Georgia's
election process is confusing,
imagine trying to explain it
to Herschel Walker.
[ Laughter ]
Pennsylvania Lieutenant Governor
John Fetterman
defeated Republican candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz yesterday...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...in the state Senate race.
Oz says he's just happy
he doesn't have to pretend
to root for the
Philadelphia Steelers anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Democrat Maxwell Frost yesterday
became the first member
of Generation Z elected
to Congress,
while Chuck Grassley recorded
another win
for Generation Zzz!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
was booed this week at the
Houston Astros World Series
Championship Parade.
As well as the bank,
the grocery store,
[ Laughter ]
his office,
[ Applause ]
and at his house.
All in all, a pretty average
week for Ted Cruz.
[ Laughter and applause ]
President Biden and former
President Barack Obama
posted a video
on Twitter this week
[ Laughter ]
reminding people to vote.
You know, it's nice to see
they're still friends.
The only way we're getting video
of Trump and Pence together is
if Maury springs it on them.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Maryland yesterday became
the 20th state
to legalize marijuana,
which means that,
for the first time ever,
there's something to do
in Maryland.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Former President Trump voted
in yesterday's midterm elections
in Florida, then,
because he can't help himself,
took a bunch of ballots back
to Mar-A-Lago.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a Brooklyn man
who was on the run
from fraud charges
was arrested recently in Florida
after the federal agent
who signed his arrest warrant
spotted him
at a Disney theme park.
[ Laughter ]
Huh!
It's a small world.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Always. end. with. a dad joke.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody!
Wow! We got a great show
for you tonight.